did he do the thing where he like walks
down the stairs onto the stage all the
women he walked by just fainting I know
he kissed a pregnant lady's stomach yeah
they're in the car that night she's like
we're naming him Drake
my husband's like what the [__] we have
to it's decided how did that happen did
she like was she wearing a short top and
her stomach was poking out yeah for some
reason pictured him just like unbutted
like unbuttoning a t-shirt
yeah like he passes her and then like
looks comes back feels her stomach yeah
he's like how many how many months then
he gets on stage is like this lady right
here is pregnant
she says she's six months
I just kiss her stomach I think we just
started over because I gave her
something new in there and then DJ and
then the song comes on maybe with my
hair thinks like
her husband just next to her
worst show ever